[Music]
it's tough being a zombie and it's not
your constant hunger for human flesh or
the slow decomposition of your body it's
food from
hi I'm dr. Gary blunt licensed
podiatrist and zombie apocalypse
survivor did you know that 100% of
zombies deal with persistent foot
related aggravation take a look at how
the average zombie walks the feet buckle
in towards the middle zero arch support
it's a real mess that's why I created
these zombies orthopedic shoes for the
Living Dead it's the only corrective
shoe for zombies with built-in orthotics
that self adjusts as your feet right
because if you're gonna be stuck in a
hellish nice craving limbo you might as
well walk straight try these shoes in
just 28 days later you'll see major
results turn that slow shuffling twist
student terrified of you but they'll
also be impressed but don't take it from
me listen to these satisfied customers I
know what you're thinking
why would a human doctor create a
product that helps the zombies and
Howard's a'm be pay for this product
well the fact is so take it from me dr.
Benson placement don't settle for the
shoes you died in order zombies
orthopedic shoes and get a new lease on
dead zone deviation let's make you
faster it will simply make their polish
non-existent slightly more comfortable
find out and get a freed up by the NFL
girdle
[Applause]
yeah
[Applause]